So here's the answer. The first one is always equivalent to
the string s, remember what it means to use the colon when
there's nothing on the left side means, start from the beginning, and
when there's nothing on the right side, means go all the way
to the end. So if there's nothing on on either side, that's
selecting the entire string. So the second one's a little trickier, but
this also always has the same value as the string s. And
the reason is, we have the original string s, and we're concatenating
to it the string s index 0, colon negative
1 plus 1. Well, negative 1 plus 1 has the
value 0. When we index from 0 colon 0, that's
an empty string. And the reason that's an empty string
is because we're starting from 0. And we're stopping just
before 0, there are no character between 0 and 0
so that's an empty string. Adding the empty string to
itself, leaves the string empty. And the interesting thing about
this is, this works even when s is an
empty string. If s was an empty string, s index
0. That would produce an error. It's trying to
select the first character from s, and there is no
first character since s was an empty string. But
s index 12 colon 12, even though there is no
12th character of, of s, since there is no
characters between there, it's okay that s doesn't have them.
That's going to valuate to the empty string. So, the third
one is also always equivalent to s. It's selecting from the
beginning of the string, position 0, all the way to
the end. Again, as we saw here, even if s has
no characters, this is still okay. It will give us
the empty string, if s has any characters, it will give
us all the characters in s. This first one is not
equivalent, and this might be a little surprising. It sounds like,
well, it's selecting all the characters from the beginning
to the end, because negative 1 is the index of
the last character in s. But remember that the selection
stops before the last character. So what this do, will
do will give us every character besides the last one.
So let's see that in the Python interpreter. Were going
to print s index, colon, negative one, and this will
give us all the characters except for the last one.
So the final one is the most surprising. That this actually
is always equivalent to s. It's equivalent even if s has fewer
than 3 characters. So the first part of selecting all the
characters from the beginning up to
position three, not including position three,
and then we're concatenating that with all the characters of s
from position 3 to the end. If s has less than 3
characters, well this is going to be empty. There are no characters
from position 3 to the end. But that's okay, we're going to
add the empty string to the characters before
position 3. So here's how that works in
the python interpreter. We'll do s from position
beginning to index 3 and add that s
to index 3 to the end. That produces the same string. And if we do this with a
shorter string. Let's initialize t to be the string, Hi. We can print from
t to position 3 plus from t to position 3 to the end. We don't get an error.
We get the string Hi out. So, this indexing
subsequences is very resilient. It works even when we index
positions that don't exist in the string. This is
different from when we were doing indexing of particular positions
by themselves. If we did index t, index 3,
that will give us an error. Because there's no character
at position 3.